What does it take to actually move to the UK as an international student and to become a qualified clinical psychologist here? Not the glossy version, not the website version, but the real version. Today I'm speaking with Dr Samuel, originally from Hong Kong but now a UK qualified clinical psychologist working in the NHS. And we're unpacking international student fees, visas, NHS access, assistant psychologist posts, the clearinghouse process, And of course what it's all like navigating a system that wasn't designed with you in mind. If you're an international student wondering, is this even possible for you, then this episode is your roadmap. If you find it useful, please like, subscribe and comment for more.
作为一名国际学生，究竟需要付出什么才能真正移居英国并在这里成为一名合格的临床心理学家？不是光鲜亮丽的版本，也不是官方网站的版本，而是真实的版本。今天我采访了塞缪尔博士，他原本来自香港，现在是一名在英国国民保健署（NHS）工作的英国合格临床心理学家。我们将探讨国际学生学费、签证、NHS医疗服务、助理心理学家岗位、清算所流程，当然，还有在并非为你而设计的系统中摸爬滚打是什么体验。如果你是一名国际学生，正在纳闷这对自己来说是否可行，那么这一集就是你的路线图。如果你觉得有用，请点赞、订阅并留言以获取更多内容。
Hi, welcome along to the podcast. I am joined today by Dr. Samuel Chu, a qualified clinical psychologist. Hi, Samuel. Hi. Thank you so much for being here and thanks so much for connecting with me on LinkedIn. I feel like you've been in my world for quite some time now. I've been seeing your name pop up. And for pitching this episode to me,
嗨，欢迎收听本期播客。今天和我一起做客的还有合格临床心理学家塞缪尔·朱博士。嗨，塞缪尔。嗨。非常感谢你能来到这里，也非常感谢你在领英上与我联系。我觉得你进入我的世界已经有一段时间了。我一直看到你的名字弹出来。感谢你向我推荐这一期节目，
because you're really passionate about there being more international students, becoming trainee psychologists, and ultimately becoming qualified psychologists who then begin practicing in the UK, aren't you? Yeah, no, yeah. Thanks for having me here. I think it's amazing that you have this platform for, you know, people like myself to share what it's like to,
因为你非常热衷于让更多的国际学生成为见习心理学家，并最终成为合格的心理学家，然后开始在英国执业，对吗？是的，没错。谢谢你邀请我来这里。我觉得你能为像我这样的人提供这样一个平台，来分享在英国从事心理学是什么体验，这真是太棒了，
to be practicing psychology in the UK as a person that isn't born here. So I think it's, yeah, to demystify this entire process is very good. Thank you. And I really do see the value of having different experiences culturally and, you know, in terms just of our own interests and, you know, our own backgrounds and, you know, the way that we see the world. you tell our audience a little bit about, I guess, what brought you to the UK and kind of how things have been for you since? Yeah, so I'm from Hong Kong, born and raised there, kind of
作为一个不是在这里出生的人，在英国从事心理学工作。所以我认为，揭开整个过程的神秘面纱是非常好的。谢谢。而且我也确实看到了拥有不同的文化经历的价值，你知道的，就我们自身的兴趣、背景以及我们看待世界的方式而言。你能否向我们的听众介绍一下是什么促使你来到英国，以及之后的情况如何？是的，我来自香港，在那里出生并长大，
studied my entire life in Hong Kong up until undergraduate. So I think throughout my kind of life in Hong Kong, I've always been interested in psychology, not specifically clinical psychology, but just the idea that, you know, we get to try to understand a little bit better about the way we think, the way we feel and the, and why we are, you know, behave the way we do. And when I was choosing my university, I was thinking about either going to a university in Hong Kong or in the UK. And what drew me to picking UK for my university choice is, you know, how good. good the research is. I think UK is leading on a lot of different areas in psychology. And, you know, I've never really gone out of my own country. So I thought at that time it would have been an experience to sort of step outside of my comfort zone and pursue something that I
可以说我的一生都在香港学习，直到读本科。所以我觉得在香港生活的整个过程中，我对心理学一直很感兴趣，不是特指临床心理学，而只是觉得我们可以更好地理解我们的思考方式、感受方式以及我们为什么会有这样的行为。当我选择大学时，我考虑过去香港的大学还是英国的大学。吸引我选择英国大学的是这里研究的质量。我认为英国在心理学的许多不同领域都处于领先地位。而且，我从来没有真正离开过我的国家，所以当时我想，这将会是一次走出舒适区、在一个完全不同的国度以及一种不同语言的环境中追求自己感兴趣事物的经历，
found quite interested in in a completely different country and a language that you speak from. But since then, I've been here for eight years now. Yeah, and, you know, it's been good. It's been good. I've learned so much throughout my entire journey in clinical psychology, living here, working here, different language, different cultures. So, yeah, have a lot of feelings and experience from that. Amazing.
我发现我对一个完全不同的国家和一种与你所说的语言不同的语言很感兴趣。不过从那以后，我已经在这里呆了八年了。是的，而且这一切都很好。我在临床心理学、在这里生活、在这里工作的整个旅程中学到了很多东西，不同的语言，不同的文化。所以，是的，我对此有很多感受和经验。太棒了。
I have to say, I felt pretty adventurous when at the age of 18, I moved from Milton Keynes to Wales to do my degree. But you're making me look pretty, pretty timid there. Yours is very, very much more bolder and a bigger and braver decision. Like I'm, I am going to the UK. I am moving to London. Yeah, no, I mean, it was, I mean, I was 18 back then, right? So what do you know about like, about the world and the significance of your decision
我不得不说，18岁时我从米尔顿凯恩斯搬到威尔士去读学位，当时觉得自己挺有冒险精神的。但你让我看起来相当怯懦。你的决定要大胆得多，也更大、更勇敢。就像我在想：我要去英国。我要搬到伦敦。是的，我是说，当时我18岁，对吧？所以当你处于那个年龄时，你对世界以及你决定的意义又能了解多少呢？
when you're, when you're that age? And I wouldn't imagine that people might plan a lot when they're young. They just like, okay, I want to do this. Let's just go for it. And I'm quite fortunate to be able to do that. So I think, you know, looking back to it, sometimes you wonder, wow, how could you have made this decision? You know, you didn't know so much about what it's like living in a foreign country. But you learn a lot along the way.
我不认为人们在年轻时会做太多的规划。他们只是觉得：好吧，我很想这么做，那就冲吧。我很幸运能够做到这一点。所以我觉得回过头来看，有时候你会想：哇，你怎么能做出这个决定？你对在异国他乡生活并没有太多的了解。但你在这一过程中学到了很多。
You learn the struggles that a lot of people have gone through. And then you go through yourself. what it means to be an ethnic minority in a country, what it means to think and speak in a different language, to have your life sort of completely reset, where you kind of put yourself in a complete different situation, a new situation, and then how we can navigate around that, and what you learn from being able to navigate around those difficulties.
你了解了许多人经历过的挣扎，然后你亲自去经历。了解作为一个国家的少数族裔意味着什么，用不同的语言思考和说话意味着什么，让你的生活彻底重置——你把自己置于一个完全不同的、全新的环境中，然后你如何去适应它，以及你能从克服这些困难中学到什么。
And I think, yeah, I think it makes you a more resilient person, I'm in the end and I would imagine being a trainee or future trainee would you go through similar things as well. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, like I hear you when you're 18, we're just like, yeah, I'm going to do that, it's going to be fine and everybody else will just fall into place around me and it'll be fine. That was certainly my experiences anyway. So you apply to the UK, you applied to to learn to university in london to do your undergrad and i presume there's some sort of visa stuff to sort out as well and then you're able to come and stay for those three years initially or is it a little bit longer than that how did that process look so in order to study in the UK you need when
我想这最终会让你成为一个更有韧性的人，我想成为一名见习生或未来的见习生也会经历类似的事情。是的，完全同意。我懂你的意思，18岁的时候我们总是觉得：是的，我要这么做，一切都会好起来的，周围的人也会自然而然地配合我，一切都会迎刃而解。这确实是我的经历。所以你申请了英国的大学，你申请去伦敦的一所大学读本科，我想这其中也有一些签证方面的事情需要处理，然后你就能来这里最初停留三年，还是说时间要长一点？那个过程是怎样的？所以在英国学习，你需要
you go a tier four visa so what this means is that you need an conditional offer from your university or an unconditional offer and then you apply through the government to get a tierful for visa and with that visa it means you can stay here and study here for the duration of your university degree and you also get an X amount of hours to be able to work not full time but you know part-time and then afterwards once your tier 4 visa runs out you usually get a i think two-year graduate visa where you get to stay here to look for jobs and once you do find a job you then need to kind of negotiate for work visa. So kind of this is sort of the process that it might have changed over the years, but this is generally what should happen. Yeah, okay. And I think I'm right
当你出发时，你需要持有第4层级签证。这意味着你需要获得大学的有条件录取通知书或无条件录取通知书，然后你通过政府申请第4层级签证。有了这个签证，意味着你可以在这里停留并在你的大学学位期间在这里学习，你还可以获得一定数量的工作时间，不是全职的，而是兼职的。之后，一旦你的第4层级签证到期，你通常会获得一个我认为是两年的毕业生签证，你可以留在这里找工作。一旦你找到了一份工作，你就需要去协商工作签证。所以这个流程大致是这样的，虽然这些年来可能会有所改变，但大体上就是这样。是的，好的。而且我认为我说得没错，
in saying that when you're an international student, you do actually pay more fees for your undergraduate and your postgraduate study than you would if you were a home student. So if any international student is looking at the website, they might well notice that the international fees are advertised as higher. And that can be a bitter pill to swallow because in essence you're not getting anything different and you're having to pay more for it. Yeah, yeah, I think you do pay it significantly more
那就是作为一名国际学生，你的本科和研究生阶段学费实际上比本土学生要高。因此，如果任何国际学生查看网站，他们很可能会注意到国际学费被标得更高。这可能是一个很难咽下的苦果，因为本质上你并没有得到任何不同的东西，却要为此支付更多的钱。是的，是的，我认为你确实付出了明显更多的学费，
and there is no loan that you can have from the UK government. You know, I think the only loans that you might be able to get is through your own government in your own kind of country. So it is a significant amount. You have to pay for your own accommodation, food. You have to pay for the NHS, unfortunately. So that will cover national insurance. So I would, you know, encourage students, no matter what level you're undergraduate,
而且你无法从英国政府获得任何贷款。据我所知，你唯一可能获得的贷款是通过你本国的政府。所以这是一笔不小的数额。你必须自己支付住宿费、食物费。不幸的是，你还必须支付NHS（国民保健署）的费用。这将涵盖国民保险。所以我会鼓励学生，无论你是本科生还是研究生，
postgraduate, you know, you've already paid for NHS. You might ask, and you should register for your local GP as well. You know, I've seen a lot of international students where they didn't even even know that they could access at the NHS, they thought they had to pay for it. So definitely register for a local GP so that if there is something come up, it's better safe and sorry that you have these resources. Great, so it sounds like you pay kind of a yearly fee, which would be your national insurance, which would then allow you to access hospital services, emergency mental health
你已经支付了NHS的费用。你可能会问，而且你也应该注册你的当地全科医生（GP）。我看到很多国际学生甚至不知道他们可以使用NHS的医疗服务，他们以为自己必须为此付费。所以一定要注册一个当地的全科医生，这样一旦有什么情况发生，有备无患总比没有好，你拥有这些资源。太好了，听起来你支付的是一种年度费用，也就是你的国民保险，这可以让你享受医院服务、急诊心理健康服务、
or routine mental health services, GP, and then also being able to go to renew It might be helpful to say an NHS dentist that you get treatment that you then have to pay a little bit more for as your NHS fee. So nobody really gets the free NHS dentistry, but you get it heavily subsidised. But once you're paying your national insurance as an international student, you are able to use those services as if anyone with a British citizenship would be able to. Yeah. Okay, that's so interesting. And I'm actually really good friends with someone that runs a student mental health support at a local university. And I know that for international students, it can be really lonely because often people move without their family.
或是常规心理健康服务、全科医生，还可以去看牙医。也许可以说，NHS牙医提供的治疗你需要作为NHS费用额外支付一点钱。所以没有人能真正享受到免费的NHS牙医服务，但你可以获得很高的补贴。不过一旦你作为国际学生支付了国民保险，你就可以像任何拥有英国国籍的人一样使用这些服务。好的，太有趣了。而且我有一个好朋友，他负责管理当地一所大学的学生心理健康支持服务。我知道对于国际学生来说，这可能会非常孤独，因为人们往往是在没有家人陪伴的情况下搬迁的。
Often they've moved without any friends. And so kind of looking after your own mental health can be key, kind of. It can be a real challenge. Could you give us any kind of advice around that? especially I guess if people are coming in from an Eastern culture where actually mental health can be really stigmatized. Like, you know, I don't want people moving to the UK and really feeling like it's awful
通常他们搬来时没有任何朋友。因此，照顾好自己的心理健康可能是关键，这确实是一个巨大的挑战。你能给我们一些关于这方面的建议吗？尤其是如果人们来自东方文化背景，而那里的心理健康实际上可能会被严重污名化。你知道的，我不想让人们搬到英国后真的觉得这里很糟糕，并对他们产生负面影响。
and having a negative impact on them. Yeah, I think it is important to take it easy, to be compassionate towards yourself. I think a lot of us underestimate how big of a challenge it could be because, you know, when you are stressing about getting into the university, getting enough funding to go, supplementing yourself, visa. We sort of forget that there's actually a lot more to living somewhere completely different
是的，我认为放平心态、对自己保持同理心是很重要的。我们中的许多人都低估了这会是一个多大的挑战，因为当你正为考入大学、获得足够的资金出行、维持生计、签证等事情感到压力时，我们会忘记，在某个完全不同的地方生活，
than you would expect, given how, you know, you have so much support system in your home country. You know, you have friends established already. You have your parents, your loved ones. You know how the system works. You know where to access care. and you know the language and the environment that you have lived in for 20 years in your life. So I think it is important to be aware of first what the challenges can be, but also what are the resources that you can have around you once you are in the country.
实际上比你预期的要面临更多的事情，而在你的祖国，你有那么多的支持系统。你已经有了既定的朋友。你有父母、挚爱。你了解这个系统的运作方式。你知道在哪里获得医疗护理，而且你还熟悉你生活了20年的语言和环境。所以，我认为重要的是首先要意识到挑战可能是什么，同时也要知道一旦你在这个国家，你周围可以拥有哪些资源。
So for example, if you are here for university, there's actually a lot more resources than one might think once you have landed here. So for example, you have university support, student support that are super helpful. One of my placements when I was in UCL was in the student support team and the team was brilliant when I worked there. So there's so much support you can have. There are also a lot of societies that you can join. And a lot of those times, you know, those societies, there's like a million societies that you can join.
举个例子，如果你是为了上大学而来到这里，一旦你在这里登陆，其实会有比想象中更多的资源。例如，你拥有大学支持，学生支持团队超级有帮助。我在UCL（伦敦大学学院）实习时，其中一个实习岗位是在学生支持团队，当我工作时，那个团队非常出色。所以你可以获得大量的支持。你还可以加入许多社团。很多时候，你知道这些社团有成百上千个，
I bet one of them would be something that aligns with your own interest or your own culture. So, for example, at UCL, at almost all London universities, there's a Chinese society, there's a Hong Kong society. So, yeah, there's actually a lot more support than you might think. And I think it's important to stay connected with those support systems. Yeah. I wish I thought of that when I moved, even when I moved from Milton Keynes to Coventry to do my doctorate, I sort of arrived with an undergraduate mentality of I was single and I thought everyone else on my cohort would maybe be single and would be just be able to go out and have fun and like, you know, just be really like young free and, you know, and just have fun and explore
我敢打赌其中一定有符合你兴趣或文化的社团。例如，在UCL，在几乎所有的伦敦大学里，都有中国学生学者联谊会、香港学生会。所以，是的，这里的支持实际上比你想象的要多得多。我认为与这些支持系统保持联系是很重要的。是的。我搬家的时候怎么就没想到这一点呢，甚至当我从米尔顿凯恩斯搬到考文垂去读博士时，我带着一种本科生式的心态到达那里，觉得自己还是单身，我以为我同届的每个人可能也都是单身的，大家都可以出去玩，享受乐趣，你知道的，就是那种非常年轻、自由、充满乐趣并探索
Coventry. And it really wasn't that for me. And I was one of the only single people on training. And so I think I was lonely in the evenings and the weekends. And I used to travel back at weekends. And I don't think I ever really thought of myself as a student, because once you're working, you're doing university, you're doing placement, you're kind of doing assignments, I don't think I've really tapped into that student mentality other than the NUS discount. Like, I was down with that. But I don't think I've really thought, oh, I could have joined some local staff, like with the university. And I had the choice of Coventry or Warwick. So I think anyone listening to this, if anyone's moved for university,
考文垂的状态。但对我的经历来说根本不是这样的。我是培训班里为数不多的单身人士之一。因此我觉得自己在傍晚和周末时感到很孤独。我过去常常在周末回家。而且我认为我从来没有真正把自己当成一个学生，因为一旦你开始工作、读大学、实习、写作业，除了学生优惠（NUS discount）之外，我真的没有体会到那种学生的精神面貌。我很赞同这一点。但我不认为自己曾想过：“哦，我本可以参加一些大学当地的社团活动。”我当时有考文垂大学或华威大学的选择。所以我想任何听到这话的人，如果有人为了上大学而搬迁，
Even if you're a mature student, I think that's great advice from your Samuel, actually, is think what might be going on that might be able to support you to either develop new interests or to kind of develop and cultivate ones that you're already interested in. So that's brilliant advice. Yeah, no, I think, you know, in the end, we are social animals, right? No matter how independent you are, you know, we need people around us. And, you know, I think universities is a great way for us to try out different things. You know, even if you are on the doctorate, for example, or you're doing a master's in psychology. It's important to not forget that, you know, you're there to not just learn, but also to experience what it's like to live in a, you know, in a different place to be in an environment where other people are learning as well. and that you know it is university is a place where people of all backgrounds come together because they're interested or they want to learn a subject so there's already some relevance that you can connect with and you know i think especially studying and working in london you see so many different
即使你是一名成熟学生（大龄学生），塞缪尔，我认为这真的是一个很棒的建议，那就是思考一下可能会有哪些活动能够支持你发展新的兴趣，或者培养你已经感兴趣的事物。这真的是个绝妙的建议。是的，我认为归根结底，我们是社会性动物，对吧？无论你多么独立，我们需要周围有人。而且，我认为大学是我们尝试不同事物的绝佳途径。你知道，即使你正在攻读博士学位，或者在攻读心理学硕士学位，重要的是不要忘记，你的到来不仅是为了学习，也是为了体验在另一个地方生活是怎样的，身处一个其他人也在学习的环境中是什么感觉，
walks of lives like people from all over the world come to london to work and to study and you meet a lot of diverse people and people who are completely different and very similar to you as well. So I would encourage people who are thinking of whether or not to come to London or to the UK to study to like, just go for it. You know, how bad can you be? I love being in London. So I probably travel there about once a month at the moment. And I'm probably in London as worst nightmare because I speak to everybody. The last time I was there, I costed someone to come to help me when I was in Barbican to help me try and find somewhere.
并且大学是一个来自各种背景的人们因为对某个学科感兴趣或想要学习而聚集在一起的地方，所以已经有一些你可以与之建立联系的共鸣。而且，我认为特别是在伦敦学习和工作，你会看到来自世界各地形形色色的人——人们从世界各地来到伦敦工作和学习，你会遇到各种各样多元的人，有与你完全不同的人，也有与你非常相似的人。因此，我会鼓励那些正在考虑是否来伦敦或英国求学的人：去闯一闯吧。最坏又能怎样呢？我太喜欢伦敦了。所以我现在大概每个月去那里一次。我可能是伦敦最可怕的噩梦，因为我会跟每个人说话。上一次我去那里的时候，我在巴比肯（Barbican）时拉着一个人来帮我，帮我试着找个地方。
We went walking together and we had a big old chat and it was lovely. And then I was in the Prettamonte, jean, getting the train home. And I overheard a conversation. It was really interesting and I joined in. I just love opportunities to talk to people and learn about people and their stories. so I definitely bring some of my more northern approaches down south. But I just, I love it. So yeah, I like that idea of actually coming and experiencing some of the UK culture
我们一起散步，聊得很开心，那感觉真好。然后我在 Pret A Manger（连锁三明治店）买咖啡准备坐火车回家。我无意中听到了一段对话，非常有趣，于是我也加入了进去。我就是喜欢与人交谈、了解人们及其故事的机会。所以我确实把一些更偏向北部人的作风带到了南部。但我就是喜欢这样。所以，是的，我很喜欢这种亲自来体验一些英国文化、
and yeah, learning about it and just seeing what you make of it really. It's powerful stuff. So for you, you did your undergraduate and then you almost immediately after that do a master, Samuel. Yeah, I think you made a really good point. point about difference between the big city versus kind of smaller areas and towns. And maybe it's my own kind of growing up in Hong Kong is, you know, it is in many ways similar to London where people don't socialize with each other and they're always on their phone.
了解它并看看你能从中收获什么的理念。这很有力量。所以对你来说，你读了本科，然后在几乎紧接着就去读了硕士，塞缪尔。是的，我觉得你关于大城市与较小地区和小镇之间区别的观点说得非常好。也许这是因为我在香港长大的经历，在很多方面它和伦敦很相似，人们不怎么彼此社交，总是盯着手机看。
So they actually can be quite lonely at times compared to the northern side where everyone is treat each other like they have been friends since primary school. So, yeah, I think it is a very good point. And I think that's why having those systems in place is quite important. Because at times it can be quite lonely, you know, given how people, there's so many different people in London that sometimes they might not seem like a university campus or university life because you're walking with professionals and wherever else in London.
所以与北方人那种把每个人都当成从小学起就是朋友的方式相比，这里有时确实会让人感到相当孤独。所以，是的，这是一个很好的观点。我认为这就是为什么建立这些支持系统相当重要的原因。因为有时它确实会让人感到相当孤独，考虑到伦敦有那么多不同的人，有时它可能看起来不像一个大学校园或大学生活，因为你在伦敦是和专业人士以及其他形形色色的人走在一起。
Yeah, yeah. I genuinely say hi to everybody that I walk past in the street. Like I have made a friend in the street that was 84 at the time. And we did become friends for quite a number of years until she moved out of the area. And she got to know my children. She was a bit of her like a step-granny. and that was literally just from becoming kind of familiar strangers and then chatting. And then I also once met a friend in a car park because my little boy who was in a sling at the time had pointed to them
是的，真的，我在街上走过时会对遇到的每个人说“嗨”。比如我曾在街上交到一个朋友，当时她84岁。我们做了好几年的朋友，直到她搬离那个地区。她认识了我的孩子们。她有点像我的“代理祖母”。那真的只是从成为“熟悉的陌生人”然后聊天开始的。然后我还曾在停车场遇到过一个朋友，因为我当时用背带背着的小儿子指着他们，
and was very insistent that we go over. And that ended up with us being friends for quite a few years as well. So I really do talk to strangers, but yeah, not everybody does and you might not be able to achieve the same if you came to the UK. So Samuel, you went from undergraduate. to kind of postgraduate study. You did a master's, I think I'm right in saying. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, so after my undergraduate,
并且非常坚持要我们走过去。结果是我们也成了好几年的朋友。所以我的确会和陌生人说话，但是，是的，并不是每个人都会这么做，如果你来到英国，你可能无法取得同样的成果。所以塞缪尔，你从本科读到了研究生阶段的学习。如果我没记错的话，你读了一个硕士学位。是的，是的。是的，所以在我的本科之后，
it was an interesting time because during the undergraduate, COVID happened. So that means there was a period where, you know, there were no lectures that, you know, I was back in Hong Kong. And so, you know, during that time, I was also kind of working a little bit in research, in psychology and
那是一个有趣的时期，因为在本科期间，新冠疫情发生了。这意味着有一段时间，你知道的，没有讲座，我回到了香港。所以，你知道，在那段时间里，我也在从事一点心理学研究工作，
you know afterwards I was sort of having this dilemma of whether or not to go into academia so research university in clinical psychology so working as a practitioner or something perhaps completely different like in big data and you know AI which
之后我陷入了一种两难境地：是应该进入学术界——比如在大学从事临床心理学研究，还是作为一名从业者工作，或者是做一些完全不同的事情，比如大数据和人工智能（AI），
it's actually quite funny I think thinking back to it now that AI is so prominent and Hey, maybe I should have gone to AI work. But anyways, I end up choosing a master's in clinical forensic psychology. And I think what really influenced me into doing that is because I had an assistant psychology post back in undergraduate working in forensic psychology. So I remember speaking with one of the lectures in my forensic psychology placement. and he was basically inviting everyone, the whole class,
现在回想起来其实挺搞笑的，因为现在人工智能如此盛行，嘿，也许我当时应该去从事人工智能工作。不管怎样，我最终选择攻读临床法医心理学硕士学位。我认为真正影响我做出这个决定的是，我在本科期间曾做过助理心理学家，从事法医心理学工作。我记得我和我法医心理学实习期的一位讲师交谈过，
to see if anyone wanted some experience in forensic psychology, just email him. I end up being the only person who emailed him. And so, yeah, right? So I then, you know, started kind of going under his wing, observing some clients, client work, and I started picking up cases myself, doing psychometrics, doing assessments,
他基本上是在邀请所有人，全班同学，看是否有人想获得法医心理学方面的经验，只需给他发电子邮件。最后我是唯一一个给他发邮件的人。所以，是的，对吧？然后我开始在他的羽翼下学习，观察一些客户，客户工作，我开始自己接手案例，做心理测量，做评估，
with him. And I became quite fascinated, actually, in forensic psychology and in the way, you know, people think, feel and behave and how our earlier relationships really influence how, how we relate to the world and with ourselves and with other people. So then I decided to sort of, because I know how competitive clinical psychology is. I've seen the forums. I've seen YouTube. I've other YouTube videos of people say, you know, I've tried 10 times and I'm still, and here's my reflections and they're all super helpful actually. But I thought, you know, clinical psychology is something I've became increasingly interested in. So that is something that I want to put both fit in and yeah, go for it. Yeah. Wow. I cannot believe that of a whole lecture studio,
和他一起。事实上，我对法医心理学以及人们的思考、感受和行为方式，以及我们的早期关系如何真正影响我们与世界、与自己以及与他人的关系，变得非常着迷。因此，我决定——因为我知道临床心理学竞争有多么激烈。我看过论坛。我看过YouTube。我看过其他YouTube视频，里面的人说：“我尝试了10次，我还在坚持，这是我的反思”，其实这些都超级有用。但我想，临床心理学是我日益感兴趣的领域。所以这是我想全身心投入并去争取的东西。是的。哇。我简直不敢相信，在整个阶梯教室里，
only one person and that was you email to do the kind of the shadowing. Like I would have snapped my own arm off to get that opportunity. But it sounds like you learned a lot and it helped you to kind of think, I do, I do want to become a qualified psychologist. Yeah, yeah. And I think there is so, there's a lot of benefit in doing research obviously, you know, you get to kind of pave the way of more new evidence-based. But I think if I ever do that, I'll always have this thought in my head, like, you know,
只有一个人（那就是你）发电子邮件去争取跟岗实习的机会。为了得到这个机会，我简直愿意砍掉自己的一条胳膊。但听起来你学到了很多，它帮助你坚定了“我确实想成为一名合格的心理学家”的想法。是的，是的。而且我认为做研究显然有很多好处，你可以为更多的新循证依据铺平道路。但我想如果我真的做了那个，我的脑海里总是会有这样一个想法：
what would it be like to work with the people, you know, work with the feelings and with the emotions. And, you know, there are, of course, a lot of benefit to have those experience when you do research as well. And that's what the doctor is extremely helpful for. And yeah, and I think, you know, I end up being very lucky. I had very good mentors. I had very good experience, opportunities. And, you know, I think that's how I got onto training. Were you able to secure paid work or was it all kind of honorary, as they say,
和人们一起工作、与感情和情绪打交道会是什么感觉？当然，在做研究时拥有这些经历也有很多好处。这就是博士学位极其有帮助的地方。是的，而且我认为，我最后非常幸运。我有很好的导师。我有很好的经验和机会。我想这就是我走上培训之路的原因。你能够找到带薪工作吗？还是说在进入培训之前，所有的工作都像他们说的那样是荣誉职位（无薪职位）或是志愿工作？
or voluntary work until you got onto training? So I did secure paid work. when I was on the clinical forensic psychology, it's a stage one training in forensic psychology. So that means that we need a minimum of 60 days in clinical work. So then there I worked in a medium secure unit and as an honorary assistant psychologist. But towards the end of that, they had an assistant psychologist post that came up and I applied for it. Well, alongside many other assistant psychologist applications I did not get in. So I got into that and so I was actually, I've actually started my assistant psychologist post as a paid employee there.
我确实找到了带薪工作。当我攻读临床法医心理学时，那是法医心理学第一阶段的培训。这意味着我们需要在临床工作中至少有60天。因此，我在一个中度安全病区（medium secure unit）工作，担任荣誉助理心理学家。但在那结束时，他们有一个助理心理学家岗位空缺，我申请了。当然，我也申请了许多其他没有被录取的助理心理学家职位。所以我在那里得到了这个职位，实际上我作为那里的带薪员工开始了我的助理心理学家岗位。
And then at that point, you know, I got an offer from UCL. So then, you know, that's where I transitioned my assistant psychologist role. Okay. So people might be watching this because they're interested in becoming a psychologist or they might be watching this because they're looking at coming to the UK to do something else. but I'll just briefly explain. So to become a clinical psychologist in the UK, we have to apply through a scheme called the Clearing House. And they will sort out the applications for home students
然后在那个时候，我收到了来自UCL的录取通知。于是，这就是我过渡到助理心理学家角色的过程。好的。所以人们收看这个节目可能是因为他们有兴趣成为一名心理学家，也可能是因为他们正考虑来英国做别的事情。但我会简要解释一下。要在英国成为一名临床心理学家，我们必须通过一个名为“清算所”（Clearinghouse）的系统进行申请。他们会整理本土学生的申请，
who then would attract NHS funding. But actually, there's a number of universities across the UK, not super loads, but a number of universities that do accept international or self-funding students. And so we still use the same forms, a clearinghouse, and you still have to have the relevant experience, don't you? You still have to be able to demonstrate that you're a great candidate for this role. So it isn't like it's not going to be a walk in the park for you to be offered this place. Could you talk to us about your experiences of that, Samuel?
这些学生随后可以获得NHS的资金资助。但实际上，英国各地有许多大学，虽然数量不多，但也有一些大学确实接受国际学生或自费学生。因此我们仍然使用相同的表格，即清算所表格，而且你仍然需要具备相关的经验，对吗？你仍然需要证明自己是这个角色的优秀候选人。所以这并不是说你轻而易举就能获得这个名额。塞缪尔，你能跟我们谈谈你在这方面的经历吗？
Yeah, of course. So I think it is very important to think about the requirements to apply for, like, doctorates, different universities have different requirements in their clinical training program. So, for example, if I remember correctly, KCA has a minimum of six months, even though most people apply have a year or more. And a lot of universities is a mixture of both clinical and research experience. So clinical work could be work as an assistant psychologist, as a psychological or well-being practitioner as a perhaps healthcare assistant or kind of a clinical research assistant where you have patient-facing role as a research assistant.
当然。所以我觉得考虑申请博士学位的要求非常重要，不同的大学在其临床培训项目上有不同的要求。例如，如果我没记错的话，KCA（金斯顿大学与圣乔治医学院合办机构）的要求是至少六个月，尽管大多数申请者都有一年或更长时间的经验。而且许多大学要求临床经验和研究经验的结合。因此，临床工作可以是担任助理心理学家、心理或健康福祉从业人员、医疗保健助理，或者作为临床研究助理——在研究项目中扮演面向患者的角色。
And for research experience is basically a research assistant post or above where you sort of a part of a research project in a university program. And a lot of unis require a mix of one year of either pure clinical or a mix of clinical and research. So there is a lot of questions, I know, from different queries that the UK international trainee group has, where a lot of questions are, you know, is this clinical experience in my home country? Is it relevant when you apply for UK doctor programs?
至于研究经验，基本上就是研究助理或更高职位的岗位，在大学项目中作为研究项目的成员。许多大学要求一年纯临床经验或临床与研究相结合的经验。因此，我知道英国国际见习生小组提出了很多疑问，其中许多问题是：“我在祖国的临床经验在申请英国博士项目时相关吗？”
And most of the answer is yes. you don't need clinical experience from the UK in order to apply for training. Obviously, you might get an advantage. Let's say, you know, if the university is looking for whether or not, you know, how the NHS system work, because once you're in training, you're working in the NHS. So working in psychology, in the NHS might give you some experience in what that's like, but it is not compulsory that you need NHS experience to get onto training. And, you know, there is another section that asks, you know,
大部分的答案是肯定的。你不需要英国的临床经验来申请培训。显然，你可能会获得一些优势。比方说，如果大学正在寻找你是否了解NHS系统的运作方式，因为一旦你开始培训，你就是在NHS工作。所以在NHS从事心理学工作可能会让你对那里的情况有一些经验，但这并不是进入培训的必修条件。而且，还有一个部分会问，
what you think of clinical psychology is, responsibilities are in the NHS, and I think that's where you kind of showcase what you think it is, what you know it is. But overall, you know, it is six months to one year of clinical and our research experience, and it doesn't have to be continuous, it can be done maybe like part-time or full-time. Yeah. Yeah, thank you. And actually, since you've now qualified, I think you said that even during your undergraduate,
你认为临床心理学是什么，它在NHS中的职责是什么，我认为这就是你展示你认为它是什、你了解它是什么的地方。但总体而言，它需要六个月到一年的临床和/或研究经验，而且不必是连续的，可以兼职或全职完成。是的。是的，谢谢。事实上，既然你现在已经资格合格了，我想你曾说过，甚至在你的本科期间，
your family moved over to the UK and you are, you are, you know, working towards hopefully becoming a British citizen, aren't you? Like this is, this wasn't just a three-year impulsive jaunt. This is, this is becoming your life. Yeah, yeah. I think there is a lot that the UK offers. I think it's very different. And I've been really enjoying living in London.
你的家人就已经搬到了英国，而且你正在努力争取成为英国公民，对吗？这不仅仅是一次为期三年的冲动旅行。这正在成为你的生活。是的，是的。我认为英国提供了很多东西。我觉得这里非常不同。在经历了七、八年之后，我依然在探索伦敦。它实在是太大了。据说它比香港还要大。这太疯狂了。所以，你知道，我想我会继续留在这里，即使只是去思考作为一名临床心理学家是什么样的，以及与在其他国家相比，在这里执业是怎样的。我认为在英国成为一名临床心理学家非常不同，无论是在这里学习还是工作，都与其他地方有很大差异。谢谢。那么，在每个学习阶段开始时，你是否都必须重新申请新的签证，以确保你能够完成这些学业？
I think, you know, even after seven, eight years, I'm still exploring London. Like, it's just so big. Apparently it's larger than Hong Kong. It is crazy. So, you know, I think I will continue to stay here, if not to kind of think about what being a clinical psychologist is like and what it's like practicing here compared to in other countries. I think being a clinical psychologist in the UK is quite different, both studying and working here compared to other places. Thank you. And so are you having to kind of reapply for new visas at the start of each block of study to make sure that you're going to be able to complete those?
是的。对于本科、硕士和博士学位，你需要第4层级签证。这是你需要申请的东西。我要说的是，你不应该等到最后一刻才去申请。这确实需要一些时间，还有DBS，
Yeah. So for undergraduate masters and the doctorate, you require T for visa. So this is something that you need to apply for. And I would say you shouldn't wait until the last moment to apply. It does take a while as well as the DB. is something that we use in the UK in order to kind of prove that you have no criminal records, for example. And in order to have that check cleared, you need both a police check from your home country and in the UK. But I think getting the police check from your home country is super important before you come over to the UK. Because if you don't do that, then it might take an extra amount of effort to get that police check done. before you start training or in any kind of clinical jobs where you have faced with patients.
这是我们在英国用来证明你没有犯罪记录的东西，例如。为了通过这项审查，你需要同时提供来自你祖国的警方无犯罪证明和英国的证明。但我认为在来到英国之前，拿到你祖国的警方证明超级重要。因为如果你不这样做，那么在开始培训或从事任何需要面对患者的临床工作之前，获取该警方证明可能会花费额外的精力。
That is such good advice. And actually when I was an assistant psychologist, I ended up working in a youth prison and the enhanced DBS wasn't enough. So I was 27 at that time, I'm gonna say, and they wanted a 20 year history and they wanted references from everybody spanning that 20 years. So I actually had to write to my primary schools, which I think covered
这真的是个绝妙的建议。事实上，当我是一名助理心理学家时，我最终在一家青少年监狱工作，当时增强型DBS（Enhanced DBS）还不够。所以我当时27岁，我要说的是，他们想要我过去20年的历史，他们想要跨越这20年的所有人的推荐信。所以我实际上不得不写信给我读过的小学——我想这涵盖了
two primary schools and my secondary school and, you know, the jobs that I'd worked with, I had to get written references for everybody. So if you end up working in prisons, you might well find that you've got some additional hoops to jump through. But yeah, we do have the DBS system which stands for disclosure and barring service. And even as a qualified psychologist, I'm signed. up to the rolling enhanced disclosure that means that I pay yearly to kind of for them to check and say that I haven't been caught. I haven't got a criminal record. I haven't done anything, I should say, but yeah, I haven't got anything on my record. Yeah, and I don't think speeding fines count. So for people who might occasionally
两所小学和我的中学，还有我工作过的地方，我必须为每个人取得书面推荐信。所以如果你最终在监狱工作，你很可能会发现自己有一些额外的门槛需要跨越。不过，是的，我们有DBS系统，代表“披露与禁制服务”（Disclosure and Barring Service）。即使作为一名合格的心理学家，我也签署加入了滚动增强型披露（rolling enhanced disclosure），这意味着我每年付费让他们进行检查，证明我没有被抓到过。我没有犯罪记录，我没有做过任何……我应该这么说，是的，我的记录上没有任何不良记录。是的，而且我认为超速罚款不算数。所以对于那些可能偶尔
accidentally speed, you know, it's don't worry about that. Yeah, excellent advice. And then so now you're your, your, you're qualified. You're finding your feet as a qualified psychologist, you know, full stop, let alone in the UK. But, you know, I guess how do you, how do you take the next steps? How do you, because you do want to build this life in the UK, how do you strive to be able to do that, Sam? So I think a lot of people put training as a pedestal, so, oh, once I get on training, everything will be complete and, complete and you will know everything now and your life is complete but yeah well getting on to train it is is super super impressive and like you have done it but there's so much to life after
不小心超速的人，你知道的，不用担心这个。太棒的建议。然后，现在你已经获得资格了。作为一名合格的心理学家，你正在站稳脚跟，更不用说在英国了，但是，你知道，我想你是如何迈出下一步的呢？塞缪尔，你是如何努力做到这一点的，因为你确实想在英国建立这种生活？所以我想很多人把培训当成了一个神坛，哦，一旦我进入培训，一切就都圆满完成了，
qualifying that you don't really think about before you got on right so and you know this is I'm in a stage where you know I'm thinking about a lot of different things so what kind of psychologists I want to be what kind of psychologists I want to specialize in and also what it means to be a clinical psychologist working in the UK who speaks the different language who's in a different culture who has an English a different accent and so I think everything is sort of an experience for me and things that I then take back to reflect on. And so, you know, at the moment, I am working in a child developmental service because what is brilliant in training is that you get to experience different types of services,
你现在就会无所不知，你的生活就完美了。但，是的，虽然考入培训超级超级让人印象深刻，而且你也做到了，但获得资格之后的生活还有很多很多，这是你在考入之前并没有真正思考过的，对吧？而且，你知道，我正处于这样一个阶段，我正在思考许多不同的事情：我想成为什么样类型的心理学家，我想专攻哪个方向的心理学家，以及作为一名在英国工作、说着不同语言、身处不同文化、有着不同口音的临床心理学家意味着什么。所以我觉得一切对我都只是一种经历，我会把这些带回去反思。因此，目前我在一个儿童发育服务机构工作，因为培训中最棒的地方在于你可以体验不同类型的服务，
you know, and, you know, so I've worked in general mental health, I've worked in child and adolescent mental health, I've worked in neuropsychology, in leadership placements, and I've really enjoyed working in CAMS back in my placement. So that's what I've decided to do. And this is, again, something that is quite nice working as a psychologist in the UK, which is that you get to pick what you want to do after you qualify. I know friends who have then gone on to academia, who have gone on to adults or neuroscience or psychosis. And, you know, I've chosen for this stage in my life to work in children's mental health, which I find very rewarding and very interesting. But, you know, who knows where life will take me, right? I think at the moment I'm thinking about working in
你知道的，我已经从事过一般心理健康工作，从事过儿童和青少年心理健康（CAMHS）工作，从事过神经心理学工作，担任过领导力实习，而且我在实习期间真的很喜欢在CAMHS工作。所以这就是我决定要做的事情。这也是在英国作为心理学家工作的一个非常美好的地方，那就是你可以选择你在获得资格后想做什么。我知道有些朋友后来进入了学术界，有的去了成人、神经科学或精神病学领域。而且，我已经选择在我人生的这个阶段从事儿童心理健康工作，我发现这非常有意义也非常有趣。但是，谁知道生活会把我带向何方呢？我想目前我在考虑接下来去社区心理健康机构工作，看看
community mental health next to see, you know, what that's like and whether or not, you know, I could develop my own identity as a practitioner. Yeah, amazing. Was there anything, as you think back, that really surprised you about British culture or that you didn't see coming or were like, I cannot believe this. Well, actually, there's a lot of things, right? But maybe it actually shows the difference between my culture and the British culture. But in my culture, there is a lot of emphasis on people older as they're elderly, as someone you have to respect a lot.
那是什么样的，以及我是否能够发展出自己作为一名从业者的身份。太棒了。回想起来，有什么事情真的让你对英国文化感到惊讶，或者你没有预料到，或者让你觉得：“我简直不敢相信这个”？嗯，其实有很多事情，对吧？但这也许恰恰展示了我的文化与英国文化之间的差异。但在我的文化中，非常强调年长的人，也就是长辈，他们是你必须给予极大尊重的人。
And there are also different customs that you do, depending on age and, like, ranking. So, for example, if you are studying in a university, university in Hong Kong. You have to call every lecture or professor as Professor Chan or Professor Professor X, Y, Z, right? In the UK, you call people by their first names, which is something that I'm still a bit kind of not uncomfortable, but like it catches me by surprise every time. Where, you know, it is actually quite friendly. You know, most people are very friendly in the UK, be in the workplace. in university, if you are brave enough to talk to them, they can be quite friendly.
而且还有不同的风俗习惯，取决于你的年龄和层级。所以，举个例子，如果你在香港的大学读书，你必须称呼每位讲师或教授为陈教授或某某教授，对吧？而在英国，大家都是直呼其名，这让我至今仍感到有点……倒也不是不舒服，但每次还是会让我感到意外。不过，这其实挺友好的。你知道，英国大多数人都非常友善，无论是在职场上还是在大学里，如果你有勇气跟他们交流，他们其实可以非常友好。
And this is a surprise for me, I think, because, you know, I think, yeah. How about the British sense of humour? What should people be prepared for that? Yeah, major sarcasm. I think, you know, it is quite funny because a bit about me is because I am exposed to the Westernised. media, like I watch Netflix, for example. I'm on the internet. I'm on YouTube.
我想这对我来说也是一个惊喜，因为，你知道，我觉得，是的。那么英国人的幽默感呢？大家对此应该有什么心理准备？是的，主要是讽刺。我觉得，这其实挺搞笑的，因为我个人比较常接触西方媒体，比如我看Netflix，我上互联网，我上YouTube。
And so you already get a lot of exposure for American cultures, which, you know, I'm generalizing heavily, but compared to the British culture, everything's a lot more subtle. So I think it's definitely something to grasp. Like, for example, you know, I am very well rehearsed in what the weather is like every morning because it definitely changes by the hour. You know, we experience four seasons in the day. So I can't, and I can't believe that I didn't talk to you about the weather when we first started this podcast this afternoon. It's raining currently where I am.
所以你已经接触了大量的美国文化。虽然我在以偏概全，但与英国文化相比，英国文化要微妙得多。所以我觉得这绝对是需要去体会的一点。比如，你知道，我对每天早上的天气情况可以说是了如指掌，因为它绝对是每小时都在变。你知道，我们一天能经历四季。所以，我简直不敢相信，今天下午我们刚开始录制这个播客时，我竟然没有跟你聊聊天气。我所在的地方目前正在下雨。
You might not surprise anyone watching this. Could you tell us a little bit about where people can learn more about you, where you are on social media. Tell us about your YouTube channel, Sam. Yeah, so I have a YouTube channel called Sam who's psychology, where I share a little bit of bit about you know my own thoughts and feelings about what it's like studying in UCL which was where I was trained and also a little bit about what the application procedure is like and I know Marianne also has her own extremely lovely and professional website so you can do that as well and you know I also have my own
看节目的观众可能不会感到意外。你能跟我们简单聊聊大家在哪里可以更多地了解你，你在哪些社交媒体上活跃吗？给我们介绍一下你的YouTube频道，萨姆。好的，我有一个叫“萨姆心理学”（Sam who's psychology）的YouTube频道，我在上面分享一些关于我在伦敦大学学院（UCL）求学的心得和感受——我就是在那里接受的培训，同时也会分享一些申请流程的相关信息。我知道玛丽安也有她自己非常精美且专业的网站，大家也可以去关注。而且，你知道，我也有我自己的
website to think about kind of working in private practice so at the moment I am I have my own little private practice where I see kind of adults and young people who are looking for mental health support. I am also kind of engaging in a lot of therapy and psychoeducation and webinars for people who are in marginalized communities who really want more access to psychological help or psychological knowledge. And I think it is super important for us to remove these barriers to mental health and to psychology. And so I'm doing that as well. And for any other prospective international candidates that might be interested in clinical psychology, of course there is another committee called UK International Training Committee that is being run by a lot of my lovely friends and colleagues. So there's that as well.
网站，主要考虑的是开展私人诊所的工作。所以目前我有自己的一个小诊所，接待那些寻求心理健康支持的成年人和年轻人。我也在为处于边缘化群体、真正渴望获得更多心理学帮助或心理学知识的人，开展大量的治疗、心理教育和网络研讨会。我认为消除这些通往心理健康和心理学的障碍对我们来说超级重要。所以我也在做这方面的工作。对于任何可能对临床心理学感兴趣的未来国际候选人，当然还有一个由我的许多好朋友和同事运营的委员会，叫做英国国际培训委员会（UK International Training Committee）。所以也有这方面的资源。
Perfect. I will make sure that all the details are in the show notes and in the description if people are watching on YouTube. Thank you so much for this chat. It's been really fascinating. Thank you for your time, Samuel. If anyone has got any questions, any comments, drop them in the chat and we'll do our best to keep an eye on those. Thank you, Samuel. Thank you. Thanks for inviting me again. Oh, you're more than welcome. What an absolute delight to speak with Dr Samuel. Thank you so much. much again, Samuel, for spending your time and sharing your wisdom with our audience. If you would welcome learning more about UK clinical psychologists and people's roadmap to becoming them, you can absolutely check out. The Clinical Psychologist Collective inside is over
太棒了。我一定会确保所有详细信息都放在节目shownotes以及YouTube的视频描述栏里。非常感谢你今天的聊天，真的非常迷人。谢谢你的时间，萨姆。如果任何人有任何问题或评论，请尽管发在聊天区，我们会尽力关注的。谢谢你，萨姆。谢谢。谢谢再次邀请我。哦，不用客气。能与萨姆博士对话绝对是一大乐事。非常感谢萨姆再次花费时间与我们分享你的智慧。如果你希望进一步了解英国临床心理学家以及他们是如何走上这条职业道路的，你绝对可以查看《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective），里面汇集了超过600年的临床经验。
600 years of clinical experience. That is hard to replicate. It gets wonderful reviews on Amazon, if you've read it already, please do consider leaving me a review, as it really does help us to demonstrate that it's a very good read. And if you really like what I do and would like to help me to make this a sustainable podcast, please do consider joining either the first look access or the backstage crew membership, which you can do on either captivate, YouTube, or Apple Podcasts. All the details are in the show notes or the description. And if you'd like further insight and guidance and support from qualified psychologists to help you in your own journey towards training and beyond please do check out the aspiring psychologist membership which
这绝对是难以复制的。它在亚马逊上获得了极好的评价。如果你已经读过了，请考虑给我留下一个评价，因为这真的能帮我们证明这是一本非常好的书。如果你真的很喜欢我的工作，并希望帮我让这个播客能够可持续地办下去，请考虑加入“抢先看”或“后台工作人员”会员，你可以在Captivate、YouTube或Apple Podcasts上加入。所有的详细信息都在shownotes或描述栏里。如果你想从合格的心理学家那里获得更多深入的见解、指导和支持，以帮助你完成培训及未来的职业旅程，请务必查看“有志心理学家会员计划”（aspiring psychologist membership），
you can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term details are available and you can join at www. aspiring hyphen psychologist.co.com.uk and if you would like my advice on your career for free why not go along to my website where you can request your free psychology guide and let me know your most pressing psychology concern right now. And I, these actual fingers, will type you a bespoke answer, a bespoke reply. So why not do that? Head to the bottom of the welcome page at my website, www. aspiring hyphen, psychologist.com. your guys with this podcast that's your side to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with dr marianne There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你只需每月30英镑起即可加入，没有最低期限要求。详细信息均已公布，你可以访问 www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk 加入。如果你想获得关于职业发展的免费建议，为什么不去我的网站看看呢？在那里你可以申请获取你的免费心理学指南，并告诉我你目前最迫切的心理学困惑。而我，将用我这双真实的双手，为你键入一个量身定制的答案、一个量身定制的回复。所以为什么不呢？前往我网站欢迎页面的底部，网址是 www.aspiring-psychologist.com。通过本播客获取指导，让你在成为合格心理学家的道路上稳步前行。这里是玛丽安博士主持的《有志心理学家播客》（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。